політичні центри євросоюзу вищі
російську чуєте після літніх канікул у team
харчування безвізового режиму для України
перед пріоритетними на порядку довгому
упор шипуни діалогова раз треба побачити
до сюди україни марія габріел представила
звезли вчора з косово невис у профільному
комітеті у депутата тепер 10 днів для
за повагу після отелення куміте дугласова
тема за проповідь youtube збільши піску
сувати і візи дали виразити лежачи настил
європарламенту вуста точно слову за радуй
з цим подібних трохи члени комітетів ж ви
означало вся їжа засідання на місяць
жадібну критику
а ваша за ікла що наш ви че треба-то
україні безвізовий режим
інсайдери його прогнозу вич штативу руку
action plan for visit eberle ісландії
ще до візової лібералізації це було
реально дорожня карта реформ туман і не
викликали паралізація за конкретний крок
рамках нашого партнерства for all apart
нашої
у team за реально скошування віс-віс
мутив і ший після тубули в євросоюзі
думаєте що до механізму при зуб і нині
безвізовому режиму
німецький євро депутат alex von у чеку та
рахунок стає протягом зріс не з
механізм малюка застукає skype таким
червоний дозволить знати і spain умову з
нідерландами та кейв крик не проголосував
та ставок та асоціації україн-єс
на мою думку колими думова мася про
механізм про зуб і на не аби зірку
гаражемо у ми на ті основі
ще раз , нідерланди він сам з механізмом
стіни голенда кіно обидва мис чоловік і не буду
маска зате ще в тілі в цьому емоція
netherlands in an open це лінга тієї
фірмі
для українець та механізм означає чуров
форми slide реально вправо животи
жадібному разі не ними туго ти я хочу
україна за голему та реформи євросоюз
можна вимити обмаже і рук злочинці
безвізовий режим за вакано ним києвом
реформ скаже йому єврокомісія до
побачити його європарламенту
теж політично з дуба так і вояка від
вже видніється на взутті можемо ми пірат
вириті з історичної провал
і так і провал стасова там і ціна вища
безвізовому режиму алла європейських
перспектив України чи 700c дуже важливо
я чим їх вітчима через садок чи короткий
убуд і розум з україни я в європейському
союзі
ми хочемо розуму ти фарбуєш державу красти
розумом і функціонал, а не йти і держави
підписав угоду про асоціацію якщо
взяти на себе забув я зайнятий немає прямого
ти україну знайшли хори форм головне щоб
україна сама з нього нас поганого